よろしくお願いします
今日初めて参加なさっている方々もいらっしゃいますか？まあ
じゃあスケジュール通りに行けば
まず説法で それから自由に瞑想する時間でございます
もし瞑想指導必要だと思う方々いらっしゃるならば
瞑想の時間で聞いてください
それが終わったら 皆様方に自由に反論するなりに質問するなりに
いろんなことを自由にできます
で 午後は何時まででもよろしいし
体にもよろしい ご飯食べないで仏教を喋ると
ですから このいろいろ質問やら疑問やらね
反論やら 納得いかないところやら
そういうところはもう遠慮しないで
どんどん出してみて 話し合ってみたりすることは
瞑想終わってから自由な時間ございます
そういうわけで 私はできるだけ説法の時間を短くしようと思って遅くしましたけど
あまり時間なくて この前の法華経の第1第2偈の説明はもうすごく大雑把で
しっかりは終わらなかったとは思います
第1の第2の偈では言っているのは大変な難しい話で
ちょっと今日少しだけそれについて喋りますけど
この自然科学しか知らない世界では
物質しか存在しないと思っているんですね
そこで 科学が発展する前に
この知識がなかった時代で
人間が体に魂があるんだよと言っていたんですよ
変わらない魂があるんだぞと
この魂に体を支配されているんだと
そうすると それはもう昔の話で
それで科学というものが出てきて
物は実験して試してみるという方法が現れてきて
まぁ試してみようと思ったのも
思っても手に入るのは物質しかないんだから
物質の研究をして 随分この物質しか存在しないという風に結論付けているんですね
そういう結論というのは非科学的なんですけど
科学者言うと科学的という立場ですからね
でも私から見ればあまりにも馬鹿げた話で
証拠ないものは言うなよと
物質しか存在しないんだよという証拠はありません
で 仏教はこの永遠不滅の個体的な魂みたいな霊的な存在はまるっきり否定する
それから物質の存在もそう簡単に肯定しているわけじゃないんです
仏教はどちらでもない
ものすごい難しい 人間に難しい
この無常ということを話しているんですよ
無常 無常って言ったら
なんでそれかと思うでしょうね
これこそ世の中では一番理解難しい話なんですよ
無常は 私は今日 他の言葉に入れ替えてみます
で ものあると まぁ科学的にみんな自然科学のでは考えていますね
で 仏教ではものがあるではなくて
全てどう ですよ どうとものと比べてみてください
まぁ一切は同であるということ
同というのはこのムーブメントということでね Function
といえば 英語で使えばFunctionという言葉なんですけど
できれば全て同で考えてみてください
例えばこちら紙 1枚ある
これは物でしょ でもものは存在しないんですよ
これがなんで同になるんですか？なり得るんですかと
同だからこそ 我々は一時的にものにして言葉使うんですよ
紙という その紙という言葉っていうのは
ただ一時的なある同に
ある同の連続性に使っている言葉で
その言葉のせいで紙は存在するという錯覚が起こるんですよ
そこで我々は何かに神と言ったら
その何か仕事をしてくれなきゃ神とは言わないんですよ
では 私は今手に取っているこのマイクロフォン
なんで皆様 これにお箸と言わないんですか？言葉だからいいんじゃないんですか？箸と言いましょうと
言わないでしょうね なんで？その仕事をしてくれないんですよ
箸の仕事 箸は まああのイントネーションが分かりませんだから
まあ食べる箸でも割る箸でもどちらでもいいんですけど
その仕事をしてくれないんですよ
なんでこの本を見て じゃあこれにご飯と言いましょうと言ったら笑っちゃいますよ
なぜならば この本はご飯という仕事をしてくれないんですよ
それが同の世界なんですよ
そこでこの本を食べる虫に何と言いますか
しみしみしみしみしみね
例えばしみにしてみれば
これはご飯ですよ その仕事をしてくれるんですよ
で そこはもう子供にわかる世界同の世界で
なんで何かに言葉をかけているかというと
何か働きがあるんだからなんです
どうだからなんです 同っていうのはどう頑張っても同だから死にはなりません
死っていうのはストップ
だからなんでこの世の中は死の論を語っているんですかと
死っていうのは死ぬ字ではなくて
このストップの死 ストップの
同と死 だからものがある
実体がある 答えがあるということは
死の世界なんですよ そこからの観察能力はおかしくて間違っているんですよ
だからブッダの世界は同の世界で
物理学から見れば この素粒子なんかは研究する時だけなんとなく触れよう触れようとしている世界なんです
だからもうそれは物理学のもう究極的なところで
そこを素粒子の研究したりするんですけど
なかなか大変ややこしくて難しくて
それも仏教はそういうところからスタートしているんですね
ですから この原始的な自然科学と仏教はあまり比較しない方がいいんです
そんなのはまだまだ原始的なんです
そういうことで 仏教は同ということの話になっていて
そこら辺でナールーパと心と物質という 2つの働き
2つの道なんですよ 心という物体と物質という物体があるという話じゃないんですよ
で そういうところ その同の流れ 2つで考えると
ナマという心という同の流れが強烈で強い
んだと それが物質的な動を支配しているんだっていうのは仏教の話なんです
それでこの素粒子なんかはこの波動か物かという疑問
今でもあるでしょう あの
クアンタムとかなんとかって言ってる分野の世界ではね
そこで波動で取っちゃうと物でなくなっちゃう
物で取っちゃうと波長が崩れちゃう
それからどうしても観察する研究者の
科学者の気持ちによって結果が変わるんですよ
物質だから私の希望通りに動くはずないでしょうに
でも素粒子になってくるとそうじゃないんです
物としては動かないんですよ
しかし 物質の世界は素粒子でできているんです
一個一個物質は物として動いてくれないんです
だからそこら辺は私は知ってる世界ではございませんので
何も明確な説明できませんし
どうしても必要というならば
いっぱい研究論文は持ってきますけど
でも私には読んでもわからない
いくらでもそんなのを揃えるのは簡単ですけど
で クアンタム理論と英語で言ってることなんですけどね
まあこの不確定論というのはものすごく見事に悩ませているところなんですね
我々はそんな悩むことではなくて
これ不確定で変化するんだよということは仏教
最初から言ってるんですね
だから悩むなかれと 変化するんだから
そこでその道の話なんですね
無常っていうのは そこで第1第2芸で本当に言いたがっているのは
このその道  2つ見てみると
どちらが支配してどちらが管理者であるというと
その心というものであると
だからそんなにこの物質にしがみついて
もう死に狂いで当たる必要はないんだよと
物質が悪ければ自分の心が悪いんだからだよと
そうするとそんな変な話と
でも実践の世界で見てください
すごい単純な世界で そうすると
いとも簡単に答えが出てくる
だから究極的なだからではないんですけど
究極的な難しい論理を発見するためには
一番単純な例で見ればわかるんです
面白いことに では これ考えてみてください
この世の中 なぜこの自然が自然破壊しているんですか
なぜ今我々に体に良い食べ物やらなかなか手に入らないんですかね
なぜ自然は破壊しているんですかね？誰が悪いんですかね
人間と言ったっても心でしょうに
思考でしょうに だから誰かのアホが原子爆弾でも一つ落としちゃえば
これでもうすごい長い間
人間苦し苦しまなくちゃいけない
それ放射能を浴びた人々の子供が生まれたっても
子供まで影響を受けたりする
放射能はもう延々と次から次へと飛んでいくんでしょうね
連鎖反応で放射能の草食べたら牛の体放射能
その牛を食べた人間にも体に放射能が入っちゃうし
その人がどこかに用を足しちゃうと
そこら辺の虫たちやらそちらにもその影響が入っちゃう
その人が子供作っちゃうと
その子供の体までそうやって連鎖反応で次から次へと物質変わっていっちゃう
それで物質論は置いておいても分かりやすいんだから
なぜそうなったかと なぜそこまで自然を破壊すること
変えることできたかというと
分かりやすい人間の心でしょうね
で そこは究極的なところに持っていけば
それはいい加減じゃないんですよ
あるのは心という道と物質という道ですから
それで心という道が偉くて支配しているんだったら
今も我々は物質を支配しているはずなんです
だから明らかに我々は支配しているでしょうね
その服なんかどんな木から取ったんですか
服を作る木なんかありますか？ないでしょうに
人間がもう自然にないものを作ってるんではないんですかね
そういう風なところで考えたら
やっぱり物質は心に支配されていると
心の好き勝手だよと という論理成り立つ
そこまでいくらか何となく論理的で哲学的で科学的みたいな話なんですね
そこで仏教はそこで終わらないんだから
故に 悪い心を持っちゃうとひどい目にあいますよ
だって物質を悪い方向に変えるんだから
清らかな心を持っちゃうと良い方向に変わりますよと
そこでストップするんです
なんでストップするんですかというと
残りは自分でわかるでしょうに
頭がいいんだったら 次に何が言いたがってるんですかと
君たちは決めなさいよと
どっちにするかと そうすると心を清らかにするべきということが当たり前の論理として成り立つ
ああそうですか わかったと
変える人にはお釈迦様は愚か者やという
だって何か新しい真理を教えたところで
何か新しい考え方が生まれてないんだから
ではどうするべきかという
問題の解説 説明だけでは終わってはいけないんですよ
そうすると現代日本の社会と同じくなるんですからね
ずいぶん解説する なんで株が下がるんですか？なんであれになるんですか？なんで経済はいつでも底を打ってるんでしょうかとかね
それでなんで少々株が上がってるんでしょうかとかね
なんでアメリカの経済状態はいいのに株が下がってるんです
説明ばっかしでどうするべきかということは誰にも一つもないんですね
ではどうすればいいかと
それで昨日見たんですけど
この経済的な経済学的なプロ中のプロたちなんですけど
で で これからもう2人がいて
株の値段はどれぐらい上がるでしょうかと
来年あたりまでの計算
予測でしょうね 一人が円
それはその人はプロだから
すごい考えて出している答えでしょうね
もう一人が円あたりにしているんです
いえ それは 1,000 じゃない
1万ですね 一人が 1万1,000 で
もう一人は 1万4,000 ぐらいで
3,000円の差があるんですよ
これ恐ろしい差でしょうね
株の値段で考えると ということは
みんなアバウトでいい加減ではっきりしていないということなんですよ
そこは科学的な答えだと言っちゃうと
私が笑いますけど 科学的な答えだったら
2 たす 2 は 4 で決まっているんであって
だからそのアバウト論で考えるだけであって
答えが出てこない ですから
仏教では 一応仏教の話に戻りますけど
心が全て支配していてという言うならば
物事は心によって管理されているというならば
心が悪ければ悪い結果になると
それもお釈迦様が教えてくれる当たり前のことで
前の 決まりから真理から 2番目の真理が自動的に成り立つ
条件付きだから心が悪ければどうなるかといえば
当たり前で物質のことも悪くなるんだよと
良ければどうですかと
良い方向へ変わるでしょうと
そこからどうすればいいかという道徳的な話になるんですね
そこは自分で決めればいいのです
聞いたいというのは 少々知識があるんだったら
やっぱりということは悪い心は危険であると
清らかな心は大変幸福である
では私は清らかな心を作らなくちゃいけないんだというところまで聞いた人が考えなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 仏教は理解できるのは知識の人だと
インテリの人だと もう一応言っておいておるのです
で 何でも信じるだけの人だったら考えるということはしないんですね
考えると言ったっても
この世の中の考え方っていうのもえらい迷惑で
もうただ妄想だけで考えるということは
事実に基づいて言えるところまで考えられるところまで考えて
それ以上わからないとストップしなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこでキリがなく無限に考えるということは無意味で
単なる脳の回転で何の意味もないんですね
事実に重さつけてないとどこまででも飛んじゃいますからね
ということでちゃんと考えると
まぁ心清らかにするべきという結論が個人個人の心につくんですよ
これは個人が自分の責任でやっぱり清らかにしてやるぞという決まりが出てくる
それからまたさらに仏教は親切
そこからは親切です そうすると相手が清らかにはしたいんだけど
どうすればいいんですかと
わからないんだと というと
では教えてあげますと
言って 人の人格に合わせて
人の能力レベルに合わせて
性格に合わせて 綺麗に心を育てる方法
方法を教えているんですね
まぁ そういうところはこの 第1 第2 北経の第その偈で言いたがっていることなんです
世界は動であると 静ではないと
この動という言葉は 私は日本語で入れたんであって
ダイナミズムという言葉を私は英語で使うときも
英語で喋る場合使いますけど
無常というのはインパーマネンスというのはダイナミズムということであると dynamic
ということじゃないんです
それは英語で考える人々に使うんだからよしてください
もう dynamic とダイナミズムというのはまた 2つです
意味は で 日本語で dynamic と言ったらまた世代違いますからね
考えが意味はね で まぁ
それはそれで 無常っていうのはこの動という意味なんです
で それは修行すると 瞑想すると自分で体験できるんですよ
研究室であまりわかるわけじゃないんですね
研究室でも物質の動はわかるんですが
ちょっと問題あるんですね
外のことをいじるだけであって
自分のことはしようとしないんですね
ですから 科学的な研究室でも
素粒子をいっぱい研究して
研究して やっぱり動だよと結論を出すかもしれませんだけど
でもそれで人格はそのままなんですよ
人間が全く変わらないんですね
そのままで だから仏教では己の研究しなさいと
外の研究はしてもしてもしても
骨が折れて終わるだけだと
研究終わる先に自分が死んじゃいますよと
自分がそのままで ですから
すごい もう世界一流の科学者とそこら辺にいる普通の人々と人格的には何の差もないんですよ
全く同じ人間がふざけたり
悪いことをしたり 嘘をついたり
金のためなら何でもやったりとかね
もしかするともう奥さん不倫したんだぞと言って自分の奥さん殺すかもしれませんよ
科学者でも だから人格はそのままということなんです
殺さなかったならば それは研究に忙しくて暇がなかったからなんですよ
別に人格できてるわけじゃないんです
その考える余裕はなかったと
だからそういう何もしないで
もう 1 日ボケーっとしてる人にとっては
奥さん不倫しちゃうと考える余裕があるんだから腹が立って殺してしまう
それだけのことですから
別に人格が上がってるわけじゃないんです
そういうことで 仏教は自分を
研究してみなさいと と言っておいたんです
では今日はこの三番目と四番目なんです
アッコッチマンアワディマンアジニマンアハシメ
イエタンナウパナイハンティウェーランテサンナサンマティ
スピーカー消したんですか？では
そう来る人々には聞こえないかもしれません
あ 聞こえないんだからマイクを外したんです
なんかバカバカらしいんだから
あ 今は はい スピーカーの側に座っている人はうるさいというならば
別なところに座るしかないです
あるいはスピーカーを移動させるとかね
私にうるさいんだから消してやるぞということはあまり道徳的じゃないんです
なんかね これ別れるようになった
もう一つ二つ空いてあったのに
そちらにいる人にとっては最悪ですからね
とにかくいくらなんでも
です だからわざとそちらに座ったことは自分の業だから我慢するしかないんですけど
座った人の顔になってますから
あだから涼しくないね
空気を戻して アッコッチマンアワディマンアジニマンアハシメ
イエタンナウパナイハンティウェーランテサンナサンマティ
それで意味 アッコッチマン
私を罵って罵られた 何でしたっけ？我を罵った
アッコッチマン アワディマン
何でしたっけ？我を害した
アジニマン えーと 我に打ち勝った
アジニっていうのは勝ったということで
マンというのは私をなんですけど
パーリ語だったら ですから日本語になると私に勝ったと
アハシメ 強盗ですか これは
次の言葉 え？強奪 我々から強奪したと
このようにイエタンウパナイハンティ
ウパナイハンティは こちらは思い抱く人と書いてますけどね
ウパナイハンティっていうのはそのようにもう
もう盲々と考えることなんですね
頭の中で いわゆる頭の中の思考はそういう風に持っていく
ウェーラン 彼の怒りはナサンマティ
消えることはないんだと
そこが意味で アッコッチマン
私を罵った アワディマン
私に害した もう害したっていうのは
これは蹴ったり 痛めつけたり
殴ったり そうやってこの体に痛めること
体に痛めつけることなんですね
一応あの身体的なあの攻撃なんでアワディっていうのはされたこと
アジニっていうのは このあらゆる競争で自分に勝ってしまうことなんですね
他人が勝つ アハシは強奪で強奪で
まあ自分のものは奪われてしまう
そのことを考えちゃうと
ずっと もう怒りに狂ってしまいますよと
それ自体 いかに心が悪くなって恐ろしくなるかという
この方程式 式教えているんです
この方程式で人間の心がどんどんどんどん
人間ではない 生命の心がどんどんどんどんひどくなっていくんですよ
で 心がひどくなると 当然ながら結果も悪くなってしまう
ですから この偈は単純なことではないかと
そうやって軽々く見ない方がいいんです
で 今日こちらで来るまでいろいろなことを考えましたけど
で 考えてはいけないんだけど
やっぱりスイスイ考えちゃうんです
で このお釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉の中で
一言葉取った人がそれを勉強して膨大なものを作っちゃうんですよ
例えば仏教ではパンニャーという言葉があるんですよ
このパンニャーということは智慧という意味で
で 日本語の漢字に入れちゃってハンニャとも読みますからね
そこでパンニャーというこの一言葉は何なのかと
昔の人々はかなり研究というか
勉強してみたんですよ
そこで大乗仏教で膨大なパンニャーについて
ハンニャについての経典やらテキストやら膨大な量があるんです
全てたった一項目なんです
パンニャーということで
みんな知ってる般若心経もありまして
金剛般若心経もありまして
またもう10万 100
万偈で もうそういう風にもうサハスリサタサハスリパニャパーミタとかね
すごい膨大な量あるんですよ
日本の禅寺なんかに法事なんかに行ったら
たくさんテキスト持ってきて
あのパラパラと空気入れたりするでしょ
あれは10万何とかとか
100万とか何とか偈と言ってる
パンニャパーミタ経典全部読んだことだそうですね
まあ読めるわけはないんだから
まあ一応空気ぐらい入れてあげたり
まああれとする儀式やってますよ
だからあれぐらいたった一言葉の説明ですよ
だからまあ正しい思考もあるし
変に湾曲したところもあるんですけど
それはそれでかなり研究したことは確かなんです
そこで仏教ではシュンヤという一言葉あるんですよ
全てシュンヤだよと またた一言葉お釈迦様おっしゃっちゃう
おっしゃるんですよ それが空ということなんですよ
では空論についてどれほど膨大な大乗の世界ではテキストあると思いますかね
単純に まあお釈迦様が全て因果法則ですよ
説明したところ 因果って何なのかと
それみんなお釈迦様の教えの中から研究を始めるんですよ
いろいろ回転させて回転させて
一般人にわかりやすくわかりやすくすると
どんどんもうもう手に負えないほど大きくなってしまうんですよ
ですから この宗派仏教
部派仏教 あるいは大乗仏教の各宗派っていうのは
ああいうお釈迦様おっしゃった一言葉
仏教だ 自分たちの宗教だとしているだけのことで
それはもう現代時代になってくると
もう大乗でもなくなっちゃって
変な宗教になってしまったんですが
昔の古い大乗仏教ではたくさん宗派がありましたけど
それはお釈迦様おっしゃった一言葉なんですよ
全てじゃないんです だから
それは否定的に見るんじゃなくて
こういう風に見たらどうですか
お釈迦様の言葉っていうのはどれほど大きいものかと
ですから このパーリ経典で出てくる言葉も
一言葉二言葉取ってみても
まあ説明しきれないんですよ
かなりの意味があるんです
ですから 人間にも容量というものがあるんだから
全てわかってやるぞ 勉強してやるぞという
その傲慢さを持っちゃうと一つもわからなくなるんです
私は何で法句経をまた始めたんですかという終わりまでやったんですよ
一つもわかってないんです
いつでも全部早く終わって
全部やって そして傲慢さしかなかったんですね
知ってやるぞと できるわけじゃないんです
だから 一つしっかりと理解しておけば
それで他のものも見えてくる
一つ知ったら完全ではないかもしれませんだけど
そちら辺に説明していないところは他の経典で出てきて
それをきちんとやっちゃうと
全体的にブッダの教えは何なのかということがわかるんですよ
ですから 大乗仏教で空論を語ったところで
道徳はきれいさっぱり落ちてしまった
因果法則を説明しようとするところで
唯識論なんかはもう悟りまで
本当に悟れる方法を説明したかったんですけど
それさえもできなくなってしまったとかね
そういう風にどこかで矛盾になってしまうんですね
一部だけ取っちゃうと
でまぁ それはそこら辺で
一応この言葉はね 私を罵ったとか思う人の怒りは消えませんという
ものすごい単純な考え方なんですよ
お釈迦様はわざと誰にでもわかるように
そういう風に教えているんです
しかし そちらでおっしゃっているのは
心がどのように機能するかという
ある方程式なんですよ
そこでずっと心っていうのは何か考えているんですね 1
日中 考えている時は何かパターンができちゃうんですよ
全て法則ですから あるパターンでしか動かないんですよ
だからそれは因果法則で
この冷房は冷房にするか暖房にするか
それぞれなりに中の機能するパターンがあるんですよ
今のパターンで動いてもらっちゃうと
決して暖房にはならない
で 我々はもう簡単にそのスイッチ入れるだけで暖房にするか冷房にするかと
でも中はもう全く逆に機能するんですよ
ですから 物質のものを見ても
どんなものにもあるパターンがあって
そのパターン崩すことはできません
因果っていうのはそういうことで
リンゴの種を植えたところでジャガイモを採ったということはありえないんです
そうすると この世の中では何も成り立たなくなっちゃうんですよ
何も計画も立てなくなっちゃうんですよ
だって人がもうもしリンゴ
もうちゃんと畑を作って蒔いておいたところで
なんだジャガイモができちゃったと
で 次の日はもうなんかもう落花生出てきちゃったと
だからその人はどうやって
何もできなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから我々は人間と付き合っている場合でも
相手のことは分かってないんだけど
いくらか相手があるパターンで動くそうと分かっているでしょうに
それでなんとなく無事人間関係持ってますよ
そのパターンというものをね
そこを変えるものじゃないんですよ
このパターンは何なのかというと
これは因果法則なんですね
それで自由に考えるとか
偉そうなことをみんな言ってますけど
人間に自由に考えられないんです
自分で何かちょっとしたパターン作っちゃって
その中でぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる妄想しているだけなんですよ
そんなに立派に考えてるんだったら
どれほどこの世の中良くなっているんでしょうかね
ですから 私は一つ高慢で言いますけど
私は本を読みませんよ
でも ものすごいこの読書にもう凍り固まっている人々もいるでしょうに
でも知識はどうですかね
新しい考え方を何かしようとすれば
新しいアイデアを出そうとすれば
私はいくらでも出して見せますけど
そういう読書で何年も研究している人って
なんでそんなにも硬いんですかね
なんで何か質問したらすぐ答えられないんですかね
だからこの結局は世の中ではもう自由思想ないということなんです
読書する人であろうか
もうみんな何かのパターンがあって
その中でぐるぐるぐるぐる回っているだけで
ですから 自由思想っていうのはもう普通の人には成り立たないこと
ただ口で言っているだけで
思考は自由ではないかと
私も言いますよ それは私が言う場合は一つ即加えます
妄想は自由ですよと あまりにも激しく私に攻撃したりする時は
それはもうあなたはもう妄想するのはあなたの自由ですからどうぞと
それで怒られますけど
でも私は楽なんです それから私に攻撃しないんだから
だから妄想は自由なんですけどね
妄想は嫌ででも自由なんですよ
どこまででも回転するんだから
事実に基づいて考えているものじゃないんだからね
だからその場合は自由というよりは
この無限に回転する 果てしなく回転するということなんです
それで自分の妄想を自分で管理できるんですかね
できんでしょうに だからどこで思考の自由があるんですかね
果てしなく妄想するのにではコントロールしてみなさいと
ストップしてみなさいと
瞬時にスイッチ入れ替えて別なものを考えようとしなさいと
だから因果法則でこの自由という思考は潰れます
因果法則ですよ リンゴの種を蒔いたならば
もうそこでジャガイモを食うことはやめた方がいいんです
蒔いたのはリンゴの種だったら
リンゴの実しか出てこないんです
そういうわけで このやたらに自由やとかね
そう言ったっても 考えてみるとそうでない場合もあります
因果法則ですから 全て
だから世の中で人間の思考は自由ですか
人間は自由に生まれたものであるとか
そんなのは仏教にとってはゴミだけであって
もう相手にしない思考なんですよ
西洋の哲学とかね 中国の哲学とかね
まあ好き勝手に妄想しているだけで
もう別に真理に基づいて言っているわけじゃないんです
人間は自由で生まれたんだそうとか
どんな科学的な根拠あってそんなことを言うんですかね
その自由に生まれるわけじゃないんですよ
因果法則の結果として生まれるんだから
その生まれた人はその因果法則の中で手を足を踏まなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから日本語 日本でよく言うでしょう
このもうさせていただきますという表現はね
特に宗教的な世界で まあいろいろもうよく使うんですね
すごくありがたい気持ちで
で そういう場合は誰かにやらせているような感じになっちゃうんですね
で 仏教は誰かにやらせてるわけ
誰にもやらせることはできません
では 自分で勝手に幸せになっているので
なっているんでしょうか？と
それもできません 因果法則というのはそういう話なんです
だから自力も他力もじゃことじゃないんです
そういうことで 人間の思考も人間の考え方も
もうパターンがあって
そのパターンでずっと妄想している
だから いくら考えたっても
ひとかけらの成長は見えません
じゃあ頑張ってみますよとか
瞑想してみますよとかね
すぐ飛んでくるんですけど
全然成長は見えません
だから思考パターンは全く変えませんだからね
それに私はちょっとケチをつけちゃうと
それから口をきかないという状態になる
そういうことで難しいことなんですね
理解してほしいなのはね
もう本当に知恵で見ないと
それで ある人間がこの攻撃的で
あの人 私を罵ったと 私に勝ってしまったと
そういう現象を見るようになっちゃうと
罵られたこと 自分が負けたこと
自分が負けたことではなくて
相手が勝ったこと どんどん結果として当然確実に嫌な気持ち
怒り 憎しみが生まれてくるのです
そこで怒り 憎しみが毎日毎日燃えて
燃えて 燃えて 燃えて 燃えて
燃えて これはもう内たる原因で思考するのは自分の中でしょ
外から影響は入りません
外からエネルギーが入らなくても自己回転するの
心の働き どうなんですよ
だから心と物質はお釈迦様は別々にしているんです
物質の場合は外からエネルギーあげないと
回転しないんですよ 自力で
[背景音楽]だから地球にしたってもうずっと自転しているんだけど
それはやっぱりエネルギーをもう与えているんですよ
回るために しかし 物質の物質の物質の世界でもね
外からエネルギーが入らないと
そのその時の動がそのまんまだよと
昔のニュートンさんの科学ではね
そういう風には言っているし
例えば宇宙空間で物体に何かスピードが入れちゃうと
それはずっとそのスピードでスピードは減ることはないんだと
逃げられませんだからね
他の原因に変えられませんだからね
心の場合はもうもう同じ法則で影響を受けたりはありますが
やっぱりこの自己回転するということはものすごくあるんですね
それは心の道の法則というかね
決まりなんですね だから回転したことがエネルギーになって
次の回転を引き起こす
その回転したことがまたエネルギーになって
次の回転を引き起こすならば
どこまで回転するんですかね
無限に回転しちゃうんですよ
ですから 輪廻も成り立っちゃうんです
輪廻っていうのは その無限の回転のことなんです
物質のエネルギーではなくて
この心のエネルギーの
だから それをストップやというためにちゃんと証拠を出してほしいんですよ
止まることなく回転する
で そこでこの思考する場合は
私を罵った 罵ったと 私に勝ってしまったという風な方向性で言っちゃうと
怒るのは怒りなんですね
そこでまた同じことを妄想するでしょ
また怒りが生まれる また同じことを妄想するでしょ
また怒りが生まれてくると
だからその不幸の連想はどこまでやるかと
一旦始めたら まあどうにもならんですよ
そこが心の法則の危険なところなんですよ
一回ちょっと心の回転がちょっと変わったら
まあいつでも無限大に回転することだから
方向性変えちゃうと その方向でもういくらでも
回転していっちゃう だから同じ方向で回転するとどんどん強力になるんです
どんどん強力になる だから
ほんのちょっとのことで怒ってしまえば
それからそれを思い出す
ちょっと私をちょっと叱ったんではないかと
貶しちゃったんではないかと
罵ったというところじゃないんです
まあこっちっていうのは
まあそんな罵るというぐらいのではなくて
叱ったというね だから一言コラと言ったで
それだけでも十分です
それで嫌な気持ちになって
すぐにそれを思い出す
また思い出す また思い出すと
だから原因はほんのちょっとのどうでもいい
ほんのわずかなことなんですよ
でも心の中でどんどん怒りが膨張して膨張して
それでその人は何するかわからなくなるでしょ
最終的にはもう精神的にももう錯乱状態で
もう狂ってしまうんですね
わけもわからなくなっちゃうんです
同じ軸は回転する だからそれは明らかに精神的な病気なんですよ
もうこの精神医学的には
西洋思考ではもう精神的な病気や病気やという人がやっている同じことを誰でもやってるんです
いわゆる事実と関係なく何か妄想することなんですね
だからそのパターンが頭にあると
もうみんな精神的な病気で
重病で末期状態で もうどうにもならん状態になっちゃうんです
だから怒りがちょっと何か生まれた
ちょっと一言誰かに言われたら
それはもう頭の中でまた次の回転に使うことをしちゃうと
そこでパターンができちゃって
ずっと持っていく それで相手に相手を罵ることもあるし
相手を殴ることもあり得るし
相手を殺すこともあるし
もう相手一人ではなくて
何人にも迷惑かけることもあるし
その同じパターンで戦争まで起こる
大量殺人まで起こる ちょっとした心のくだらない病気なんですよ
イスラエルとパレスチナの問題にしても
どちら側にももうあいつが悪い
我々のものを奪われたとかね
と思っているんだからですよ
ユダヤ人も自分のもの奪われていると思っているし
パレスチナ人も奪われていると思っているし
そこで誰が言っても解決はなし
平和条約は立てません
だから解決したければ
まずあの愚かな思考を止めることでないと答えではありません
あの愚かな精神的な病気の思考を持っている限りは
もう危険でありますよ
やはり世の中のテロやらね
それはもう消えませんと思いますよ
インドとパキスタンはもう仲良くはしないと思います
なかなか大変ですよ もうアメリカへ行っても聞いてくれないのですけど
やはり南アジアの国々まとめて聞いたら聞いてくれますけど
気持ちはわかりますから
それでもすぐまた喧嘩になる
この前も原子爆弾があれしたところでお互いにまたもう状況が悪くなったところで
自分の国でまたそういう人々を集めてね
じゃあ仲良くしましょうと
言うんだからどうしようもない
わかりましたって握手をして
お互いに仲良くするようになるんだけど
また一旦帰ってからまたちょっと時間経つと
またもう 火が燃えちゃうんですよ
で なぜかというと この思考パターンなんですよ
例えば なんでイスラム人がイスラム我々の宗教イスラムだから
私たちの私たちには国を別に欲しいと
どこかでイスラム人が現れちゃうと
どんどん広がっちゃうと
その国の中でそこの人々に別な国を作ってあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
なんでそんなくだらんことを考えるかと
それも排他思考で人間を差別しているんだからでしょうに
宗教信仰どうであろうと
人間みんな同じじゃないかということは考えられません
だから排他思考で差別思考あると
私のものを罵ったという
私を罵ったということは成り立つんですよ
平等だったら罵られた
何かそれなりの訳があるでしょうと
それだけのことでしょうに
だってわけもなく原因もなく罵ることないでしょうに
わけ原因探してみれば
探したところで自分には罵られた
原因があったんだとかだったら
もうしょうがないでしょうに
しょうがない 私はこれからその原因を作らなきゃいいと
自分にはそういう原因なかったならば
相手の虫がいたところがちょっと悪かったと
なるほど 相手が今日はちょっと機嫌斜めだから
あの ちょっと罵られたんですけど
まあその自分の原因 それで終わるでしょうに
もしその人がそこをその状況変わったところで
この間大変申し訳ないでしたと
と言うでしょうね それで問題は全然燃えることは何もないんです
私は何もしていないのに
なんで罵ったんですかといきなり飛び上がっちゃうと
私と他人がそこで成り立っているんですよ
ですから これも排他思考の問題で
差別思考の問題で で とにかく我々は心の中でこの罵られたと
私に勝ったと そういう思考は使ってはいけないと
そう そういう風に考えると
幸福 不幸の元だと 苦しみの元だとどこまででも苦しむんですよ
地球は破滅になるところまででもできますよ
そのちょっとした思考で
それでまた人生を考えてみてください
罵られる 罵られることっていうのはもう卒頂でしょうに
人間の関係の中で犬見たって犬でもって時々吠えたりするでしょうに
吠えたり 何か喉から何かゴロゴロと音を出すでしょ
すごく怒った時 犬はその音を出すんですよ
時々牙まで見せちゃうんですね
犬は こちらが可愛い可愛いと思って見たところで牙見せちゃうと
それも罵ってるんですよ
カラスにもやられるし
だからこの世の中で生きている上では
罵られるということっていうのは
朝から晩まであることで
ストレス溜まって寝ちゃうと夢の中でも罵られる可能性あるし
そんなことでやっぱり私
罵られたと 私何でしたっけ
私を我を罵ったと そんなことを考えたらどうなるんですかね
だからそういうことは
世間から ずっと永久的に絶えず罵られるよということ
理解しなさいよと だから攻撃するのもあまりにもアホらしいやと
攻撃思考を持つことさえも
そんなのは世の中の普通な法則なんです
その場合は因果法則だから
自分に原因があったか
あるいは自分に原因なかったかを見たら
まあ考えたら何か原因なさそうで
それをちょっと調べればいいことであって
全く別な第三者がやったことに自分罵られることもあるでしょうに
そんなには腹立つんじゃなくて
どういうことかと調べればいいでしょうに
そこで世界っていうのはいつでも競争の世界で
それもなかなか競争ない世界っていうのは作ることはもうできませんね
そこであの人らが勝ってしまったんではないかと思っちゃう
それ生きていられますかね
勝ちっぱなしだけの人生というのありますかね
負ける方がものすごいでしょうに
たまたま億分の1ぐらいはもうちょっとしたことで事は貸すかもしれません
だからもう競争の世界で
個人には世界に対しての抗争
競争だから負けるということはもう決まりきっている
1秒1秒負けっぱなしの生き方でしょうに
それに腹が立っちゃうと
その生き方が間違ってるっていうことは当たり前当然ですね
そこで競争と言ったっても
偉そうに私にも言われたことありましたからね
そんなこと言ったって
もう慈悲やら何やらとか
やっぱり世の中は競争の世界だから
ちゃんともう攻撃しなくちゃいけない
ちゃんと戦わなくちゃいかんではないかと
私の何でしたっけ 嫌な人も嫌いな人も幸せでありますようにと
それだったら生きていられるわけじゃないんではないかとかね
で思ったりする人々いますけど
そういう人々は競争って何なのかもわかってないんですよ
24時間1秒単位で競争なのに
ちょっと一つだけ取って
例えば学校だったら学校の受験
それだけ競争にしたりとか
会社だったら自分の仕事
それだけ競争にしたり
競争だと この世界は競争の世界で
これはただの商売のことなんですよ
あまりにもおらかなんですよ
自分が奥さんと一緒に生活することも競争でしょうに
子供のしつけして育てることも
これすごい競争でしょうに
子供たちは言うことをやってくれないんだから
それさえも競争ですよ
ウイルスにしたってもずっと攻撃してるでしょうに
だから競争というもう平気で
もうもうもう単純で言うんじゃなくて
それもちゃんと生きることそのものが
もう全体的に競争ということの土台で成り立っているものだということを編み込まれているんだよというふうに理解しなくちゃいけないんですよ
スケールが大きく考えてほしいんです
ただ 会社で隣に座ってる人
やつが嫌だと それぐらいの人生ですかね
それで悩んでいて ちょっと仏教で何か方法でもないんですかと
そういうこの小さなスケールでくるかぶ仏教はないんです
全部もう巨大なスケールで物事を考える
いわゆる科学的なレベルで
この心理のレベルで そう考えちゃうと
生命というのはもう競争で成り立っている
ですから 競争は避けられない
1個の生命が無数の生命に対抗して競争している
そうすると負けるということは当たり前
この負けの連続が生きることなんですよ
それであの人がが勝ったと
私に勝ってしまったと
怒って心を壊しちゃうとどれほど不幸になるかと
だからそういうもうのは気にしないと
次の競争はあるんだから
ちゃんと競争する人にとっては
今今の 1 秒で競争で負けたら
ああ負けたあいつに負けた
悔しいって そんな時間無駄にする暇がないんです
次の 1 秒の競争あるでしょうに
それ終わったら次の 1 秒の競争あるでしょうに
それがずっと負けっぱなしでも
そんなもう忘れちゃえ
もうもう忘れちゃってるんです
次の 1 秒にチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんだから
だから勝ってるか負けてるか
全然もうもうもう余裕がない
考える余裕も だからそれがいくらかのもういくらかの明るい生き方で生きているんです
勝ちっぱなしの生き方あるんだったらそれはない
そんなものは夢描いてもう希望するんだったら
新興宗教 他の新興宗教に行ってください
よく売ってます どこにでも勝てる方法とかね
商売繁盛する方法とかね
科学的な仏教ではちょっと無理
でも我々はものすごい心理のレベルで
もう揺らぎない幸福を作る方法は教えてあげる
敵を潰して勝つということは成り立たない
敵はないと そのまま世界のことを放っておいて
こちらが勝利を得ると
その道 仏教の道なんです
そういうことで この私に勝ったと
私をいじめたとかね そんなことはもう考える必要もない
体格体力的にいじめたりすることは少ないかもしれませんだけど
それでも夫婦関係でよくよくやっているでしょうに
で そこでそればっかり思っていると
もう人生は大変なことになってしまう
で アハーシメ 私の財産は取られたということをね
まあ商売っていうのはそんなもんだからね
まあどちらか取られることありますよ
そういう まあ一応世の中に普通にあるこの機能
それについて我々の思考パターンが変になる
その起きている出来事に対する見方が
だからどうせ我々は負けてますよ
負けているのに 負けた負けた
いつに負けたと思っちゃう
そう思う このその見方が変えてほしい
その見方 このアプローチ
簡単ですよ この簡単ですけど
そのアプローチ変えることが次元を超えている人間の思考になっちゃうのです
で  4番目の偈で このように思わない人の怒りがきれいさっぱり消えるんだと
心はすごく穏やかな平安な状態になると
4番目の偈はそれを言っているのです
だから瞬時にもう次元は飛び抜けて超えている心を作られます
それが普通には想像できない思考パターンなんです
私を罵ったとか思わない思考
そんなのは 24時間だよと
私に勝ちましたと思わない
24時間だよと 私も競争しなくちゃいけないと
次の次の瞬間 瞬間のことも勝負やと
だからこの怠け者っていうのは
この  1 秒  1 秒競争しなくちゃいけないのに
それを置いておいて 負けた負けた負けたと
過去のもう終わった出来事に時間無駄に使うこと
あの人に負けたと 私に勝ってしまったと
どれほど時間を無駄にするんですかね
そんな余裕がないんですよ
人生は秒単位で変化していくんだから
その 1 秒  1 秒生きていなくちゃいけないんだから
それも競争でしょうに
だからどん底に不幸になっちゃうんですよ
もう時間は無駄に無駄に無駄に無駄に使う
それは仏教専門用語でパマーダと言うんです
でもパマーダ一言で説明しようと思っちゃうと
大乗仏教のあの いろいろ膨大な知識量みたいな
たくさん膨大なことを書かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
パマーダというのは怠ることですよ
そういうのは厳密な真理なんです
我々は 1 秒単位で怠っているんです
その余裕がないのに それでブーブーブーとくだらんことを妄想して
もう時間なくなっちゃう
考えることにどれほど時間なくなるというと
だから焦っちゃう 時間はない
時間はないと まあそういうちゃんと生きている人にとってその余裕はないんだから
ちゃんと 1 秒  1 秒の競争で
行くんであって まあもうもうこんな勝ちでも負けでもどちらでもいいことで
もうもうたまに ものすごいたまたま何か一つ勝つかもしれませんしね
だから勝ちたいという気持ちになる
それ病気ですよ 勝てないんだから
なんで勝ちたくなるん？病気ですよ
勝てないことを分かってないんだから
その病気には仏教で何と言いますか？渇愛というんですよ
ですからその二つの偈
二つと言っても一つは同じ意味だから
一つの偈で見たってもいい
同じことで心でああいう思考パターン
私に私を罵ったという思考パターン持っていっちゃうと
もう無限に不幸の世界が現れてきて
知恵はひとかけらもない
同じことしか考えてないんだから
そんな考え方をしない場合は
もう無限に知恵が開発するんです
今まで全くも気が付かなかった
想像もできなかった次元で物事を見えてくるんです
だから その偈でもお釈迦様はもう自分がこの答え
悟りという答えを教えているところなんです
そういうことで頑張ってみてください
で 思考パターン変えられるかないかということをね
思考パターン変えることをね
嫌なことは思い出せないこと
ひとかけらも心の中で嫌な気持ちを育てないこと
そういう風に頑張ってみるといいんじゃないかなと思います
日本語をお読みに方々
お読みになる方々は日本語でもありますけど
こういう偈にこの物語もつけてます
えーと それはこのどこにあるかはわかりませんが
日本語訳は  物語も読んでみてください
先生 質問よろしいですか？最初の 1 2
行のところで 物質は心に支配されているというお話だったんですけれども
これは 100%心が物質を支配しているというふうにおっしゃったのでしょう
で  100 でもない やっぱり相互依存ですから
優先どちらが威張っていると言えば心なんですけど
やっぱり 相互依存と言うんでしょうかね
プロキシプローカルというかそういう働きなんです
で ナーマルーパパッチャヴィンヤーナ
ヴィンヤーナパッチャナーマルーパと
ブッダ因果法則でそういう風に言っているんですね
ナーマルーパからヴィンヤーナが生まれると
ヴィンヤーナからナーマルーパが生まれると
それでサーリプッタ尊者がそれはこの
竹の例えで 竹 2つの束なんですけど
こうやって立たせておけないんだと
その場合はこうやって横にしておくと
支えておくと立っているんだと
その場合はこちらの竹がこちらを支えて
こちらの竹がこちらを支えているんだ
そういう風にナームがルーパを支えて
ルーパはナームを支えているんだよと言っているんですね
ですから 互いに支え合ってはいるんです
ただ 親分みたいにヤクザみたいに完璧にもうということもできません
それはもう厳密な意味でわからないんですよ
だから一番レベルの小さいところで考えれば
暑くなると機嫌が悪いでしょ
私の場合は特に それが暑いというのは外の物質でしょ
よって心が変わって お腹が空いちゃうとえらい機嫌が悪く
美味しいものを食べちゃうとまた機嫌がいい
その機嫌の悪さと機嫌の良さが
誰が作ったかというと物質ですね
ですから そうやって物質の影響を受けて心が変わるし
心の影響を受けて物質も変わる
それで機嫌が悪い時は美味しいご飯を持ってきたって
何だ言って怒る場合もあるでしょ
何だ今更とかね その場合は物質は美味しいのに
心は機嫌が悪いんだから美味しく感じないんですね
その時は心が優先に決めてしまっちゃいますね
例えば悲しい出来事が起きちゃうと
もう食べる気にもならないんですね
物質だけで考えちゃうと
お腹が空くはずでしょうし
体がガタガタ壊れるはずでしょうし
でも その時は心が優先で物質を支配しちゃう
幸福感を作ってくれません
そういう風なことで互いに影響を与えて支え合っているんです
ですかね では ここら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます